the Joe Rogan experience the gold guns
big giveaway all gold guns are you know
that's how you know yeah there's some
amazing websites that document all the
different stuff that the cartel has but
they love gold guns
yeah that's El Chapo got like a gold
very special gold gun when he was a when
he was named one one of the top earners
and for the Forbes list I think he got
his number on a gun and everything the
second to last time he got caught
because he got caught a lot of times and
escaped
somebody somebody in the military that
got him took it you know and it ended up
in the museum I think it's I think it's
in a museum somewhere in Mexico City
where a lot of these gold guns that's up
that's a war trophy for those guys right
so this is like a gold gun section of
the museum yes
yes most Mexico City yeah that's pretty
wild that gold gun gold it was a que
47th you know now if everything is so
corrupt down there how does a guy like
El Chapo keep getting popped because
when I when I saw his escape yeah I was
like this is hilarious the fact this guy
goes to the toilet and then he opens a
door and Boop he's in a tunnel and on an
electric scooter and goes a mile pops up
on the other side and they had
everything set up for him with
electricity like I mean you know the I
think the the thing that people kind of
don't understand about the corruption is
it's not just corruption because people
are greedy it's all good it's also
fear-based corruption so if you don't do
what I say we're gonna kill everybody in
your family even your dog that type of
thing I mean so after the little chapo
got escaped that last time you know all
of the staff at the jail got you know
put in prison and really so they were
all part of it there's rumors that they
were you know it seems like somebody had
to hear all that digging of course you
know he's some only a mile away they
well it was pretty deep yeah some some
some things that should have been
patrolled weren't patrolled it was a
pretty good well made tunnel for what it
was really well made
a lot of the people that El Chapo
actually used for these tunnel
operations because the same people that
he used for the tunnels in the border
region all the active tunnels there are
somewhere you know along the border all
of those guys were pulled in from from
silver mining companies that used to
operate all over Mexico that kind of
went into the toilet so they were
looking for jobs and Wow
get out shop a lot it's good job that's
poor drug tunnels you know when you saw
all that should go down with Sean Penn
and Sean Penn visiting El Chapo and Sean
Penn writing an article for Rolling
Stone my doubts were you like what in
the [ __ ] is going on here
yes for a lot of reasons that might not
be you know mainly was why are they
giving him a wire to give him the
celebrity status yeah you know there's a
lot of glorification and a lot of uh you
know people venerating some of these
people down there you know and they do a
lot our arm you know so there's
basically giving a voice to somebody it
would be the equivalent of somebody up
here giving a voice to somebody that was
responsible for a lot of damage that
done to the US you know it's why do you
think they did that like what what what
was the roman it was it was romantic
write something about it it's like
here's Sean Penn one of our biggest
movie stars yeah well one of the biggest
drug dealers ever I mean he is a Chapo
down because I've been to Sinaloa and
I've actually done classes there which
was pretty surreal he is uh he's a folk
hero
he's uh he's he's Robin Hood basically
to these people and like witness a real
moment that I had down there was driving
along this bad bumpy ride highway and
all the sudden turned into an ice that
kind of highway and the guy that I was
was with told me oh yeah this is the
cartel made this highway in the back
part of it that's the government part of
the highway
you know schools careers lawyers doctors
all their careers paid for by kartell
immigration processes of people that
want to come over here sponsorships on
the type of stuff on both sides right so
the the span of influence that's you
know that's how he kind of got to where
he was mmm he was always helping people
and he was investing in people and these
people this is these investments would
pay later on you know in a lot of ways
it sounds like he he benefited them he
benefited some aspects of the community
yeah I mean the reason why the military
couldn't get him you people so could
take eruption but because the he was
basically he had a human shield around
him you know all these towns old you
know schools hospitals every instead of
Christmas town that they celebrate the
day of the Kings you know so people get
presents Mother's Day they would all get
presents that type of thing so why would
we want to help the military come in
here and get chopped oh right doing this
type of stuff you know that's and that
is the same all over Mexico with some of
the cartels you know the hearts and mind
carts and minds type approach is what
makes some of these groups you know long
lived so how much of an effort is there
to eradicate the cartels because if you
can get a guy like El Chapo who at least
in terms of like popularity is he at the
top of the list as far lera t but at the
top he's at the top of the list as far
as popularity but when as far as like
the actual drug dealers is he at the top
of the list or they're more clever folks
that hide underground yeah there's
rumors of people above them that are
still out there somewhere that's what
everybody like that's the great
conspiracy is that like El Chapo is
basically the bank manager look it that
well you know there's a he has a
compadre you know compadres somebody
that if you're the daughter if you're
the Godfather of my my kid you know my
compadre right so he has a compadre out
there my OH Sam bodda and he is still
out there
right and the the the extent of how he
works and where he works is unknown so
he's more slick exactly
stay more low-key well there's you know
some people get sick with the fame
probably and you want to go outside once
that TV show narcos came on yeah
then everywhere people I don't I think
there's a lot of people who did not
realize how crazy the life of Pablo
Escobar was yeah and what really went
down in Colombia yeah I mean it's crazy
Pablo Escobar was a single you know that
he was a phenomenon in his time and age
but he was one man I'll imagine
replicating that type of insanity over
the span of Mexico and it's about eight
or nine guys you know mmm that was the
90s or early 2000s because these guys
were you know Legion of Doom type thing
where they would be enemies but they
would have reunions and they would meet
up and kind of agree alone you know
certain things and stuff just like in in
the Pablo Escobar show yeah yeah so they
really do that they get together and
have meetings and sometimes they kill
each other that's that's the that's the
that's a reality you know they do and at
times or did at times because things are
currently after a little chapel
you know things kind of shifted and
change what happened
well main thing is a power vacuum and
with the power vacuum and legalization
on this side of certain subsystems
substances like marijuana the the the
pot fields are now poppy fields and new
new things like like like them now
dedicated themselves to heroin instead
of instead of the weed was that's
mysteriously they're still weed fields
down there for some reason you know you
guys are way better at making it then
anybody down there but for some reason
they're still so bleep fields well I
think it's a lot of access especially in
the states where it's prohibited yeah
just there probably more willing to get
it to the people it's probably it meth
meth precursors being brought in from
China and to Mexico or now being made in
Mexico mm-hmm like in just real level
stuff right and a new a new absurd
down there that is trying to overtake
the Sinaloa cartel the new generation
cartel is coming out of wala Hara and
they're kind of really militarized kind
of wing of cartel activities that are
trying to you know take control over the
whole thing
[Applause]